mysql is one of the most popular
databases
learn how to use it in this course from
a senior database engineer
welcome to this basic mysql course i
want to start by appreciating you
for trying to learn a new skill let me
introduce myself
my name is bharat and i work for
salesforce as
a senior database engineer i have over
12 years of experience with
a variety of databases oracle being the
main one i have experience working with
companies like chase
paypal wells fargo stubhub etc
let me answer a few basic questions for
you first and that is
who what and why so who should take this
course
this course is meant for database
professionals who want to expand their
skill set
if you are a software engineer or a full
stack developer
and you want to gain a deep
understanding of mysql database
this course is for you and if you're a
college student or a computer science
student or a fresh graduate
this course will give you uh some
knowledge on database internals so why
should you learn
mysql mysql is the most popular open
source database and of course postgresql
is definitely up there as companies move
their data
from on-prem to cloud they usually like
migrate to a cloud native database or an
open source database
like mysql or postgresql in order to
save cost
so let's say that you are an oracle
database expert if you gain knowledge on
a database like my sequel
then you could help companies migrate
their data from oracle to
mysql and that can be really valuable
now let's look at
what is being covered in this course now
first of all by my sequel
i mean the mysql innodb storage engine
throughout this course which is used
behind an e-commerce website or a bank
or a financial institution
and so on and mysql offers a variety of
storage engines
my isam in-memory storage engine or some
popular
storage engines which are available we
are going to learn about mysql
in odb i am not covering any other type
of storage engines
now these are the topics that i'm going
to cover in this course and please note
that
this is a database administration course
so it is
80 database administration and for
people who are completely new to
databases i have included
sql basics so you'll be learning about
database installation
mysql workbench database indexes
database logs uh you'll also learn a
little bit of
performance tuning uh that is sql
explain
so these are some interesting topics
that i'm going to cover so what do you
exactly need to get started with this
course you need
a pc or a mac so if you're using a pc
then i recommend you to actually look
into the
worksheets or supplemental material that
is attached in the description if you
have a mac laptop
then you are in the best position to
learn this course
because then you can just see what i'm
typing and you can just type the same
commands and
just follow along from end to end and
most of
all this is the main requirement i want
you to create an
aws account that's correct an amazon web
services account
so if you don't know what i'm talking
about please do
look into my worksheet which can be
found in the description
i've attached some resources which will
show you how to create an aws account i
will be using
an aws ec2 instance throughout the
course and i'll show you how to create
one but
one main thing that i want you to
remember is so after
each study session of yours you can shut
down your ec2 instance
that way you don't have to pay any
unnecessary cost
and please do remember that you don't
have to keep your ec2 instance running
24 7.
so once you have created an aws account
and sign in you will land on this
dashboard or this page and you can go to
the services
menu right here and then under compute
you can choose easy to
so over here on the left hand side
you can choose instances and then here
we're going to create
an instance which will be our lab
environment so click on launch
instance and then
let's choose an image for our instance
so i'm going to choose a red hat
enterprise linux
version 8 64-bit and
my instance type is going to be t2 micro
which is free tier eligible
and you need to choose an appropriate
subnet
if you just created an aws account you
can just leave
leave it whatever default subnet that
shows up for you
for me i'm going to choose maybe a
specific one
and then make sure to enable this
auto assign public ip option because
that will
assign a public ip to your instance
using which you can
ssh into your instance
from your laptop and leave all the other
settings as
this
and let's allocate like 25 gigs
for the database or for the entire
instance and you can just
leave the rest as is
go to the next page where you can
create a tag for your instance
so i'm going to call it mysql instance
one go to the security group
page and then here
what's important is that you need to be
able to
ssh into the instance and
you need to you need to create proper
firewall rules for that anyone basically
anyone in the world can log into this
instance
via port 22 and that's not secure at all
and
i will take care of this instance
because
once i finish recording i usually remove
it so
i know how to handle this but when you
create rules make sure to put your
laptop's ip in there just so it's more
secure
then now you can review your
configuration
and then click on launch
but if you want you can create a new key
pair
and then just give it some name and then
download it before you create the
instance
for me i'm just going to choose an
existing key pair
maybe this one and i say acknowledge
uh maybe a different one all right this
one
and launch instance now
your instance is getting created and it
might take a couple of minutes to create
this instance
okay that's how you create an ec2
instance
and now that my instance is up and
running
and i can see the public ip uh
later i will be installing my sequel on
this instance
so that's what i wanted to show you in
this lesson
so what you're seeing is basically my
sequel documentation
showing all these different installation
guides
like windows and mac
and so on so we are
interested in linux installation or
basically my sequel installation on
linux
and there's a couple of guides actually
so
this one is basically installing generic
binary
we're going to skip that and go here and
even within
installing my sequel on linux there's a
bunch of
guides so the recommended method of
installation
is using rpm packages from oracle
but we're going to use this mysql yum
repository based
installation and it's actually quite
straightforward
so for this installation um we need to
go to
mysql.com and downloads
and we are downloading the community
edition
and go to yum repository
as you know the instance that we created
has rhl8
red at enterprise linux 8 running on it
and
so we need to download this rpm but then
we need to download the rpm on the
instance itself the one that we created
so let's actually log into the
instance so i'm going to use ssh
and i'm going to use my
private key
and login as easy to user which is the
default user
and basically get the public id of my
instance
then we log in and we switch to root
okay so one thing
that we need for downloading
this rpm to this linux instance is
wget package so let's go ahead and
install that first
all right so now the wget is installed
we need to download the rpm that we just
saw
so to get the link of this rpm we need
to go
into this download and
we have to right click here and copy the
link
and if you're installing on a different
os uh you need to click on
the appropriate button okay so we got
the link and let's just go ahead
and paste that link over here
like wget and the link
and that command downloads this
package now we are going to use an
rpm command to install this package
so this package as i mentioned before
is going to add this my sequel yem repo
to your local system repo list
with red hat enterprise linux
installation
you get like a mysql module by default
so let's disable that one
if you don't disable it then this will
interfere with our mysql installation
so let's go ahead and disable it using
this command
and don't worry about writing these
commands i will put a
link to my git repo with all these
commands
in the description so all these have
been disabled
now let's go ahead and install mysql
community server edition
using yum install mysql
community server and
let's put minus y in there
just to go ahead
and accept
all the prompts and that's installing
all these packages all right
so my sequel has been installed
let's go ahead and start
the mysql database using systemctl
command
and let's check the status
so now our mysql database is up and
running
okay so the log file of this mysql
database
software is under
war log and then if you grip
temp from this log file
you will get the temporary password for
root user and you can use that to log
into the mysql database
and how do you log in you use this
command
mysql minus u that's going to be
root and minus p
is for password paste login
and then we're logging into mysql
database
so let's use this password and see if it
logs in
and we are in and if you run any command
at this point
mysql is going to ask you to reset the
password
using alter user statement
we can do this in a different way so
there is a
executable called mysql admin and this
is the command for it
mysql admin minus u the
name and minus p password we are going
to reset the password of root user
and let's provide the the current
password which is this temporary
password first
and let's provide the
new password now all right the password
has been accepted now let me try to log
in with this new password using the
previous command mysql
minus u root and minus p my sql
let me put the password i said just now
we are in
so let's go ahead and run a simple show
databases command
which shows all the default databases
that come as part of the installation
so one more thing that we need to do to
complete the installation
is to load a time zone file
a time zone table as shown here so if i
do a select
star which is basically a sql query to
read from this table you can see that
the table is empty right now
so let's exit out and
run another command to load time zone
related data so this is the command
and let's go ahead and run it
and i'm going to go ahead and put my
password and that loads a bunch of data
you can ignore all these warnings
let's go back to our my sql database
so if you do a select star
[Music]
from mysql.timezone again it shows
a bunch of data so now you're good
and that completes the mysql database
installation
all right folks in this section we are
going to talk about data modeling
okay so database design data modeling
schema design
these are all interchangeable words
terms well database
design is an ongoing process so you come
up with a basic design
when you sort of like create your
application
and then as the application
you know gets added new features
enhancements
improvements you basically
iterate over this design right you keep
adding
new things to your design and so on so
the first thing that you do
when you're doing database design or
data modeling is understand business
data
and then once you understand business
data you have to come up with
a logical design of your database
what do i mean by that well basically
you have to
design your tables the columns that goes
into those tables indexes constraints
like primary key constraint unique key
constraint
not nail constraints default values
foreign keys like these are all various
things that you need to
create when you
[Music]
when you come up with a logical design
of your
schema once you actually have this basic
uh table design or schema design
then you can look for data redundancy
that is basically you see where your
data
is repetitive and then you
start eliminating it by normalizing your
tables actually
and that's because data redundancy
causes data anomalies
what i mean by that is when you have
like
multiple occurrences of the same data
when you are
let's say updating certain data you have
to update
in many places and if you forget to
update even
one place now you you have two versions
of the same data
in your database and that creates like
data anomaly data inconsistency
is along the same lines actually and all
that happens
because of data redundancy so what we
are looking at is basically
a spreadsheet and a spreadsheet is
basically a huge table a large
table right and
and what what we are going to do is
basically design
a table for a e-commerce website
an e-commerce website is basically like
an amazon
or ebay or whatever like online
uh business like online e-commerce
website like alibaba or whatever
right let's say like you have only one
table in this database right
and you start as the orders come in
through this website
you start putting data into this table
right you have
uh you know let's look at some of the
things that you will record
in this table right you obviously need
like
account of your order so you might like
numbering your orders
and then how it is coming like you know
is it desktop or mobile or what product
is it
like you know here i have got like a
couple of books
and then book titles and then the price
of the products
and then who's the customer customers
details
payment details delivery details and so
on
so these are all part of like uh
e-commerce
uh world basically right and you have
one giant table
and if you look at the data here right
so
you know here i've got like a couple of
customers buying
uh you know sort of like two different
prod
products right so and you can see
that the data has in been
repetitive what i mean by that is like
every time i
buy the same product i have to
repeat this data like the first order
that came in was
through the web desktop website
that was bought by bharat and then you
can see all the details of
this customer and and all the details
about the product and the payment
uh payment details as well then the
second order that came
was from a different person but then it
was
you know the the order was for the same
product and
you had to repeat the product
information
right the third was from the previous
customer
but then this time he bought a different
product this information the customer
information has
repeated actually so there is a lot of
data redundancy data has been repetitive
so this is basically a denominated
database
where you have only one table or a
handful of tables
we pack all the information from your
website for your business into
these few tables actually this is a
denominated version of your database
let's actually go look at what else you
could do
so what you can do is uh
basically you can start with this basic
denomination table and then you can
start taking out all the
redundant information out of your
database or your table actually
it first thing i did was i took out like
the customer information
i put it in a separate table right and
i've got only customer details here and
i
started like putting a id number
for each customer right or a customer
number whatever you call it
once i take out the customer information
i have
the orders table the initial table i'm
calling orders table
looking like this now right and
you can see that uh i've got like
customer id column over here
and what is this customer id column
your guess is right so this customer id
column is the same as what you see
over here right so and
why do i have that because i i need a
way to relate
these rows as you can tell like you know
these are columns these are rows
these rows i need to be able to relate
to a customer right if i take out
customer information
then how can i relate you know
this table and that table it's through a
common column uh
or a bunch of columns actually in this
case it's just one column
so customer id right i'm just like
putting the id number over here
and what else actually we can take out
of this table so this is
one level of normalization right so
let's keep normalizing
which is like take out the product
details right
so product details are also repeating so
here you don't
feel that much pain because there's only
three records in this table
what if the table has million records
right this is why we need to normalize
the table
now you actually take out the product
information and move it to a different
table
and then i have a product id column just
to number
like id the products actually and your
orders table will look like this
then you take out the payment
information to a different table
and your orders table will then look
like this
this is basically the process of going
from a denominalist
schema or a database to a normalized
database
when you have your data in a single
table
then you don't need to do any joins so
you might ask actually what are joints
actually
when you're running queries like using
sql
sql is a language right a structured
query language when you're running
commands in your database you
you can get all your data from this one
table if your
database is totally denominated whereas
if you have many tables
you need to sort of combine or
join in these tables and then you have
to get the data out
so that is called joining the tables so
when you have a denominator database you
don't have to do many joins
and that is kind of
good in a way because your database
doesn't have to think that much to get
the data
you say i want this data and this data
is available in this table so it's just
very straightforward whereas like in a
in a normalized database when you join
many tables then your
database engine which which they call
optimizer
in um in oracle or in most of the data
most of the databases
so this database engine has to think
more
as in like okay which table should i
scan first and
how should i filter the data in this
table and then okay i take the result
set from that table and i have to join
with these other tables
so there is so much more thinking there
is so much more
uh processing that has to happen on
whichever server this database is
running on right
and because of that the performance will
be kind of like slower right
and it will consume a lot of resources
and you have
all that happening at scale as in like
many
operations are happening at the same
time then
you basically have slow performance
actually
or at least slower than what it would
have been in
a denominator database but at the same
time we are removing
so much data repetition or data
redundancy is very low because of
that the storage needed in a normalized
database
is much lower so you cannot actually
like generalize and say a normalized
database will always
be slow or denominate database will be
fast
it is all like it depends actually you
have to look at the data
and see how much repetition is happening
etc etc
so but generally this is how it goes
as you go through this design process
right you know see what we have done
actually right so we have decided
then the tables that we need like you
know we have order stable products
customers and payments and we decide the
column names
and then not just that for each table
you need to
decide actually what will be the primary
key what i mean by that is the primary
key is
is a unique key and which cannot be null
actually which is very important
so using this primary key you should be
able to identify
any record in this table any row in this
table
for example if i say here
the primary key is order number
then i can anytime if i have an order
number
then i can look up this table let's say
order number equals 2
i can just get this record out of my
database
and then you need to also have like some
unique keys actually right
so unique keys is pretty much like
primary key
and unique key can be null
a primary key cannot be null as i
mentioned
and then you can also have indexes on
your table
so indexes are ways to basically select
your day
data faster let's say that i often
search this table based on
customers email then i need an
index on a customer email column
right you need to decide that and you
need to
decide about which columns can be null
right here none of the columns can be
null
let's say you have uh another column
called preference
right a customer preference as in what
kind of shipping
or what kind of or which phone number is
preferred or something like that
so that can be a null column right so
you can have null columns otherwise you
define your columns as
not null let's say like in your orders
table
you have this delivered column when an
order
is basically created when a customer
buys a product on your website of course
it's not delivered immediately
at the time of order creation the
delivered column will always have
no or n a n value right
all these things all these decisions
that we are making we're talking about
is part of schema design
and once you have all this figured out
you can put
the information in a er
design tool entity relationship design
tool
and in the next section i will show you
how i do that on sql workbench
my sequel workbench basically you can
actually then
have a pictorial representation of your
logical design of your database
right and that's basically what you call
an er diagram
and of course you can talk about the
relationship between
like two tables let's say you can say oh
this table and this table
they have one too many relationship
for example each customer
can place many orders so that is
actually a one two
many relationship right but one
you know one order can be done by only
one customer
right so so that kind of thing so you
have one to one relationship
one to many relationship or many to many
relationship between tables actually
these are all part of
uh data modeling but you don't need to
be
worried so much about that as long as
you have clear idea of like what data is
coming into your database
and along the way you need to define
like the data type of your columns
actually that is very important
your names are going to be a varchar
you know phone numbers can be numbers
and then email
is again like a watcher and your
id column or number columns are going to
be int or
number these are all some decisions that
you would make
in a data modeling
task actually that's pretty much what i
want to say about
data modeling um and there's much more
we can talk about it
and like atomicity like you you have all
the
address sort of like attributes packed
into
one uh column we we need to split that
as well so that is called atomicity
you can have address separately city
separately state separately and
you know zip code separately right so
those kinds of things there are nuances
that
make your database more and more
efficient
and of course we're not going to go into
a lot of details there
but this is the basic data modeling that
you need to understand
and as i said before in the next section
i will show you how to
take this and then input that on my sql
workbench
a quick recap of what i did in the last
section
i basically created a logical design
of an e-commerce website so what you're
looking at
is a table that i started with it's a
denominalized table
and we basically took this denomination
table
and we normalized it as you can see
there is four versions of this table i'm
calling this table orders table
so there is four different versions and
i with each
iteration i took out repeating
data so finally we landed with four
tables
apart from the original orders table so
now we have
also customers products and payments in
this video i'm gonna
take this and all these tables and i'm
going to take the structure
and i'm going to create a logical design
okay so let's actually
go to my sequel workbench and i am
already
connected to a database what i
am going to do is go to file and
go to new model so here we can
add a new er diagram an entity
relationship diagram and let's call this
database ecom store
something like that so let's go ahead
and start creating our tables
now i'm not going to be creating all
four tables
that would take probably more time or
long and i'm going to be creating a
couple of tables and
that should be enough for you to
understand how we're doing this
so let's just start with the customers
table
so the customer table has five columns
this is the icon for creating a new
table
you can drag and drop or you can try to
draw
and now double click and then create a
table called
customer and here we can start putting
the table
the column names customer id
and then this is going to be populated
by a sequence
so sequence is a database object
and it's going to be an integer
so we can leave it as this and we can
have it
as a primary key that's fine and a
primary key has to be
populated it cannot be null so that is
automatically selected
the next one is customer name we could
split that
into first name and then we can choose
watch our and maybe give a little bit
more room as in the
the length for the name and then last
name
again a watch are 100 and then
all these cannot be null so we can
choose
not null constraint so these are
different constraints which are
available
let's go ahead with the next one
address again address and if you
remember
i talked about atomicity so you want
your columns to be you know atomic in
in the sense that here basically the
whole address is packed into one column
good practice to actually split that
into
atomic columns as in address separately
city separately
state separately and then zip code
separately
so we have all these and of course
none of these can be null and what else
is there
so customer phone number phone number is
going to be
all numbers but then i want to make it
10 numbers of course not null
and customer email so can just say
email id 100 make it
not null so since id is the primary key
here or customer id
i want to make sure that that we have a
constraint
to avoid repeating customer information
for example if you have one customer's
data
for id one i don't want the same
customer
customers data to repeat for a a
different id
for example id2 so i'm going to actually
make email id unique for
each record over here and then may all
maybe phone number also
so these are all unique key constraints
or unique constraints
that's it so we have the customers
table created so let's go back and see
what else we have
so let's now create i would say
product and then you basically do the
same thing
select that just for creating a new
table
and then now here you can just draw
and this one i'm going to call it
product and we're going to go through
the same
uh process and then put the product
column names in there
and if you're wondering this is the same
customer id column that we added over
here
and we are going to make that a foreign
key in a minute
so let's go ahead and split that into
multiple columns because
again everything is packed into one
column which is not a good practice
so let's say let's call it a
credit card number
you know if the customer is using paypal
then we need a email
so we can use email id over here so this
can be null
or not null based on what payment type
is
being used so that's okay so expiration
date is going to be a date column so
let's actually change
that so if you're not sure you can
hit that the drop down
and then choose a proper data type for
each
the other thing that i mentioned which
is
uh basically about foreign key
uh this customer id is the same as what
we
added over here so let's actually make
that customer id
a foreign key so we can just call it
customer
id foreign key one
and then the table that is going to be
referenced is the customers and
the column is going to be customer id
and that's it so you can see that now we
have
a connection or a relation between these
two tables
i'm going to actually just add the
orders table as well
i've created the orders table as well
which is the main table
and i'm going to now create some foreign
keys for the orders
everything is done uh if you want to
create any indexes
at this point you can do that
so i guess we are done so we uh
basically added four tables to our
logical design these four tables and
then we
have created columns and then defined
their data types
and also we
created the foreign keys and
of course primary key and unique for
each of the tables
and you can see the the foreign key
relationship
uh you know clearly showing here
and uh that's you know that's what you
would do
to create a data model uh all right so
now actually let's just go
ahead and create a sql script
for this data model so you go to
database
and then do forward engineer
and then basically you provide the
database details where you want to
create this
these tables or the schema
so this is these are my details
continue go to the next one
provide the password all right now we
are connected i had to
try the password two three times all
right
and this has basically created a
sql script for us to create the schema
and the tables with all the primary key
unique key
and foreign key constraints
so what we can do is we can just
continue and then
now the database or the schema
is created as it goes through and then
executes that script
and close and now you can see
these tables are actually created
so you can even go to your sql editor
and then
you can start querying
your um you can start querying your
tables
there you go so you query came back
of course there is no data in it and you
can now
start using your uh database
so we actually successfully created
the basic schema or design the data
model for this
e-commerce website
a table creation or a create table
command starts with create table keyword
followed by the name of the table and
followed by parentheses
so within the parenthesis the spare of
paranthesis you have
all these column names followed by the
column data types
and followed by the constraints and you
can also use this
auto increment keyword if you want
your column value to be incremented
automatically
as you load values to the as you load
records to this table and after the
column definition
you have uh the option of specifying
the keys like primary keys unique keys
foreign keys and so on you can also
specify the storage engine type
as part of your table creation and this
is a very simple table
you can also have partition tables
subpartition tables you can have
compressed tables
encrypted tables and all these things
require
special keywords to be used in your
table definition
and please check my sql documentation if
you want
more details about the syntax as
mentioned
i'm using just integer watcher
data types the mysql documentation shows
like
all these different data types like
numeric date
and time data types string data types
like the ones i'm using
and json spatial so these are all
available
in my sql for you to use so let's go
ahead
and create this table and before
creating the table i want to run this
drop command just to make sure the table
doesn't exist
and i'm going to be creating that table
and let's see
if the table has been created yes the
table has been created successfully
i'm going to be running a select star
from the table name
to see if i can successfully query from
this table as well and then it returns
a basically it doesn't return anything
that means no
data exists in this table and that's how
you create
a table using create table syntax
finally
there's actually a default keyword which
helps you
specify default values for a certain
or for your columns so if you don't
specify a value for
this quantity column in your insert
statements or when you're loading
through procedures loading data through
procedures
it will automatically take this default
value that's pretty much
it and i'll see you guys in my next my
sequel
sequel session
so i just did a describe on the table
that i created and it has
product id product name product type
price and quantity and you can see that
uh product id is also an auto
incrementing
column right now there is no data in it
a typical insert statement
looks like this it's got the insert into
keyword in the table name
a bunch of columns within parenthesis
the ones that you want to populate
followed by the values keyword and
followed by the actual column values
if you can realize i haven't actually
specified the product
id value because it's an auto
incrementing column so let's go ahead
and execute this
and the insert statement goes through so
let me also run the select statement
as you can see the product id table
has taken the value 1 and that's
happened automatically i didn't supply
the value 1. so i'll go ahead and
commit the change and then let's
actually move on to the second variation
so this time i'm going to specify a
value
for product id nothing else is different
so just want to show you that it is
possible so it goes through
i'm gonna commit and then let's do a
select
to make sure the value has been inserted
so let's go to this third variation of
this insert statement so it's going to
be
pretty much the same except actually i'm
going to
just uh jump some values and then insert
the value
10 for this product id column i'll go
ahead and do that
it goes through a commit and uh
select again then you can see that that
is also
fine so yeah so that worked so you can
actually jump a few values
let's actually look at the next
variation again i'm going to
insert a record into this table
with no product id uh specified
exclusively or explicitly the product id
column is missing over here
and i'm going to run the insert
statement and commit
and then i'm going to run the select
statement so i just wanted to show you
that
wherever the latest value is
for this auto incrementing column i
inserted the value 10
for product id last time and then the
next time i do an
insert this auto increment uh kicks in
and then
you know increases you know increases
this value from 10 to 11. so it picks up
from the value that was inserted
last time and i'm gonna just take
another insert statement
and this time it's actually insert into
the table name and instead of the values
keyword
specifying the column names values etc
we actually select
from a different table basically if the
products three table is exactly matching
the structure of products one table
then we can do even a select uh star
from if the columns don't match exactly
as in like
products one has a different set of
columns and product three has a
different set of columns then we need to
make sure that
we actually select the columns and then
for example this product id
from products3 maps to this product id
in products1 and product name
from products3 maps to product1 in
i'm sorry product name and product one
and so on let's go ahead and run this
and see what happens
and then that goes through and then if i
now select the products one table
you can see like like all these rows
are inserted properly and basically the
products one table is populated
and then we got all the data from
products3 table
so this time i want to show you the
insert statement again
this is kind of like a bulk insert or a
multiple insert
just combined into one statement you can
see
the insert into uh clause is specified
only once but in the values
part in this clause actually we have two
rows specified
at the same time so we can even use
such a syntax and a commit and then do a
select
all good so these are a few variations
of
insert statement i hope you understood
how this works
i'll see you guys in the next session
hey my sequel learners so in this
session actually
i'm going to be talking about update and
delete statements
so as usual i'm going to be using my
ecom
store schema and i will be using my
products table to
do this demo so just quickly if we
select products table there's
two rows right now so the first update
uh is just to show you the the syntax of
updates so you have the update keyword
followed by the table name
followed by set keyword and then you can
have
as many columns as your table uh
contains uh but in this case i've got
only one
column and i can just run this update so
let's actually add one more clause to it
uh which is the where clause and this is
to
just update the rows that you really
want to update so we will be updating
only the rows with product id
equals one so let's go ahead and do that
and then i'll just commit and
select from products quantity has gone
up by
50 it went from 299 to 349. now one more
thing to realize
is actually like you can you know you
can specify literal values
uh when you are updating you know that
happens all the time or you can also
like specify
formula you can have sql functions like
replace substring
length and so on you know you can look
at my sql documentation to see what kind
of functions are available
in this update like i just wanted to
show you the syntax basically
to let you know that like you can have
multiple uh
you can update multiple rows at at once
uh in this case i put like
the values one two and three you know
you don't have to do
one row at a time or anything so when
you use the
in keyword then you can say product id
or whatever column in
and then a bunch of values to select the
rows that you want and there are other
ways to do it but
the point being you can update multiple
records
at once and another interesting usage is
uh using the case statement you know you
can let's say you have
a bunch of update statements uh one for
product id equals one
another for product id equals two and
another for uh the other product id
values
and you can combine all that into one
update statement using a case
when then end the clause or keyword
basically in this case actually for
product id equals one i want to
increment the quantity by 50 and product
id equals 2 i want to increment the
quantity by 100
and so on so then i've got this a
similar where clause that similar to the
one that i showed you before
i'm going to run this you can see the
columns are getting incremented i'm not
going to go back and check i'm pretty
sure
that it's done the right thing so the
next one is basically when
you want to delete records from a table
or purge data from a table
then you can just use a simple delete
statement and if you
are wanting to delete a particular row
again similar to the update you can use
aware class
to actually like narrow down uh the data
that you want to delete
this particular statement which is
delete from a table name and then
where column name equals at the column
value and
you can have multiple filters in here so
here i don't have the
row number three i think i've deleted it
already all right so let's keep going
products3 table i just wanted to show
you it contains a lot more data than my
other table
uh you can see it contains uh data
about 5849 rows i wanted to also show
you this
particular parameter mysql configuration
parameter
to basically enable and disable save
updates so let's say like if your
delete statement or update statement is
not
using a primary key column in the where
clause you know
then basically if you enable this
particular parameter uh let's say by
setting this
one and then if you run your delete you
will get like an error code one one
seven five and mean and then it says
you're using safe update mode etc etc
it's not leading you to run this kind of
delete statements
because it could be uh it could cause
bad performance so if i disable the same
thing
and then if i run the delete statement
and then
uh just trying to select again then it
should go through
because now the parameter is disabled
and uh
two more things one is actually like if
you have a huge table and you want to
delete
only a few rows at a time then you can
use the limit keyword
to limit the number of records that are
deleted
uh by this statement you know in this
case like i wanted to delete only 10
rows
let's go ahead and do that and it should
just work just fine
and then if i do a select you will see
the difference in the
row count actually now it's like five
eight three nine
before it was five eight four nine so
that's how the limit uh
clause helps you also in the limit flaws
you can all
specify the order by flaws uh it
basically
sorts the data by these columns like
first by quantity then by product id
then it deletes the top 10 or 100
or whatever value you put here actually
so let's go ahead
and do it and then select again yeah
2070
is gone so the top 10 rows are gone
and yeah that's pretty much it actually
those are all
a few variations of update and delete
statements and of course there's
lots of tangents we can get into but i
will leave that
task uh to you and i hope it was useful
and if you have any questions let me
know in the comments i'll sh
i'll see you guys in the next session
hey my sql learners so in this session
we'll look at select statements
not just the syntax but also like some
ways you can actually like
improve the performance of your queries
i'm going to be using the schema called
ecom store
to explain about this a select statement
in its most simple form
will look like this so you have to
select and from keywords and then
after the select you specify the select
list
which is the columns that you want to
select if you specify
a star or as trick so that actually
selects
all the column columns from this table
and then after the from keyword you
specify the table names where you want
to select the
data from so if i do a select star from
products underscore 3 it's going to
return
all the data from products underscore 3
table but
do remember that anytime you are using
a star after the select or in the select
list
you are basically querying all the
columns in this table you don't
need to query all the columns in the
table in most other cases
so you only like specify the columns
that you need to query
so in this next query let's go line by
line and see
what changes that have done to this
query to make it better so let's say i
want to select only these columns that's
why
i specified only these columns in the
select list in the from
clause i have specified products
underscore three table
very often you'll be selecting from
multiple tables you need to join the
tables and then
retrieve useful data out of it and in
the where clause
you specify all the filters all the
conditions
based on which your data will be
filtered out so here
i am including only the data which have
quantity
less than 25 so this way i'm able to
actually filter most of the data
out of this table this is very useful in
minimizing the amount of data that you
retrieve from the database
hence your queries are going to be fast
this order by is basically going to sort
the data that is retrieved based on the
columns that we specify here so here
i'm just like ordering by product name
and of course like when you're
sorting data especially when you're
sorting a lot of data
the operation can be expensive unless
your sort buffer size
that is actually the memory area where
the sorts happen unless it is sized
properly
the operation can be really slow so you
need to pay attention to that
configuration as well
and i have this other query which just
goes to show you that like this is a
very simple select statement again
in this select actually i have only the
select keyword
and a function i'm using the now
function but there are several other sql
functions that you can
use in this query for example i can
use the database function to return the
database that i am actually connected to
and as you can see i am actually able to
uh invoke
multiple functions in the same query so
that's pretty much it i'll see you guys
in the next session
in this session i will be teaching about
sql
joins let's dive straight into the demo
i will be using a schema called ecom
store and i'm creating a table first
called t1 with one column the column
name is c1
and i'm inserting these two values in
this
table one and two i'm creating another
table called t2
with the column called c1 i'm inserting
these two values
again into table t2 one
and three so it's one and two here and
one and three here
i'm going to go ahead and run a commit
to make my changes permanent
so i'm going to be just querying these
two tables just to show you
the records t1 has one and two t2 as
one and three of course a join is
an operation that joins two tables and
we have
all these different types of joints will
go one by one
and understand what they are so this is
the syntax so
select in a column list that you're
selecting
so we're joining t1 and t2 and then
we're specifying the kind of join that
we are making
and then we also have this on keyword
and then comes the
the condition on which the table is
joined so i'm going to go ahead and run
this query
and see what happens as you can see this
query this
inner join has returned the value one
so that means actually so it returns
the values that exist in both the tables
that match
so that's what inner join does so let's
just change it to a left
join go ahead and run it now the left
join is
going to return all the values from your
left
table which is t1 so p1 has
values 1 and 2 are the rows 1 and 2 and
then t2
it's going to return only the matching
values and then
for this value which only exists in
table
t1 it's going to return a null and then
i'm going to change it to
right join and as you might have guessed
it's going to return
all the values from table t2 in the
places where
there is no matching value it's going to
return a null so let's see if that
happens
that's what we expected so we got all
the rows from
t2 and then for 3 there is no matching
value in t1 you know that position has
null value now we'll jump quickly to a
union and then we'll come back to a full
join
a union is basically gonna
look like this so two queries and then
in between we have the union keyword
let's see what it returns
you can see that it's written one two
and three so that's actually
the the rows from both the tables but
it's kind of like
combined the data and then smooshes them
together
and then you have one two and three and
then let's run the same query
with a slight difference we'll put union
all and then we'll see
what happens that's written one two and
one three
so that's returned all the data from
both the tables but except
this time we have duplicate values a
union gets rid of
all the duplicate values it's almost
like a set
where you have a unique set of data a
union all
returns all the values including
duplicate data
jumping back to full join we don't have
a full join keyword so rather we do full
join
this way in my sql so basically you have
the
a similar query where you're joining t1
and t2
and left join first on this this one
column that we have
and then you have another query again
joining t1 and t2 on this
just one column but then we are doing a
union of these two
and that's going to return the data from
both the tables
we have one two these two are matching
then for two there is no matching value
so it returns a null for three there is
no matching value in t1
it returns a null over here so this is a
full join that's basically all the joins
all different types of joins that you
can do in my sequel
i hope this example was clear and i'll
see you guys in my next
session
all right my sequel learners in this
section we're going to learn about
locks more specifically i want to talk
about the
isolation levels actually so the first
thing is
just see what i have here i have like
two
terminal sessions one is in black
the other one is in slide maroon color
so i am actually going to log into the
database
as root user and i'm going to do the
same thing over here
there you go i am logged into
my sql database so i have a little
script here
to create a dummy table called t1
okay so let me show you the sql script
so at this point actually you might not
understand
the sql syntax and so on but then let me
explain
uh briefly first thing i'm doing is
setting auto commit to zero or commit is
basically a command
that you use to save your
work basically the data changes that
you're doing
uh is permanently stored
in the database when you issue a commit
command
in mysql you have this variable called
auto commit which is turned on
by default meaning all your
commands will be automatically committed
if you don't turn this off
i want to have more control over what
i'm doing here
so basically i am doing an auto commit
disable first so and then i'm starting a
transaction
and uh just to be safe i'm dropping this
table if i had already created it uh
so this table doesn't exist so it says
unknown table and
the next thing is i'm creating a table
called
t1 in ecom store schema
and then the column name is c1 and the
data type is
int and it's a primary key so and then
i'm actually inserting a
value just one row into this table
called
p1 right the one that we just created
and
i issue a commit command alter
alternative to commit is a rollback
command
so which basically rolls back or rewards
the changes that you
just done in that session so if i just
do a select
star from this table then i'm going to
see
this value so which is fine so far
so this is pretty straightforward so far
we haven't talked about the isolation
levels
so what i mean by isolation level is
when
multiple sessions are trying to
modify or access the same
data then you need locking mechanism
to make sure the data is
not corrupted or the database is
behaving
in a way that you expect to see
how you actually set isolation levels
and this is the command
so this is the other session i had open
show session variables like
isolation so that shows that the
transaction isolation
level is set to read committed right
so this is one of the possible options
actually
so this is read committed and you have
read
uncommitted and you have repetitive read
or repeatable read uh and then you have
a serializable
uh value actually so let's go one by one
right
in this session i already started a
transaction so i'm going to actually try
to update this value
using an update command so basically i
am
updating the same table and i'm updating
this column to 2
where the column value is currently 1
right so i'm going to do that the order
commit is turned off so it's not
committed yet i'm going to start a
transaction over here
and let me run a query against
the same table and just copy and paste
the table name
don't want to type it okay so we see the
value 1
which is the previous value and if i ran
the same query
over here in this session i see
uh the value 2 because this is the
session where we are modifying the data
right so and i can see the changes
before committing
in the same session here actually
since the the value of this transaction
isolation
or the isolation level is set to read
committed
it is possible only to read the
committed
data in other words when multiple
sessions are accessing the same data
in this case this column right here from
this table
apart from the session that is actually
modifying the data the other sessions
can only
see committed data any data that is
committed
just before this select is
executed so i'm going to go
here and run a commit and come back over
here and run a select
so now you see the latest data because
that commit happened before i ran this
query now let's talk about
read uncommitted isolation setting
actually
freshly log in again because these
things can get tricky
so every time i want to just recreate
the tables to
remove any confusion so let's actually
log in again okay in here and
i'm actually going to execute the same
script that i showed you before
so just disabling order commit starting
a transaction
dropping this table of recreating it
inserting this value
and then running a comment so now here
what we could do is go ahead and update
this value to 2 but remember i haven't
committed this data yet
let's go to this session and here go
ahead
and change the setting
to the isolation setting to
read uncommitted because by default it
is always set
to read committed actually
right so you can see that here so
and this is a session level setting and
you can also change it at global
level but for the purpose of this demo
we just need to change it
at the session level so session level
isolation
initially read committed then i ran the
set
session transaction isolation level read
uncommitted
and then checking the value again now
it's changed to read uncommitted
if i run a select star from this table
then i get the value 2 and if you
remember
that i i only updated the value
from 1 to 2 and you can already
see this data even though it is not
committed over here
so that is how read uncommitted works
so there is not much locking going on
here
because database is now letting the
sessions
do dirty reads because one session is
able to read
in other sessions changes even before
the commits happen actually right so
those are dirty reads
yes actually so let's go on to the next
one so we have seen
read committed and read uncommitted so
far so now let's move on to
repeatable treats actually right so exit
so here i am going to just commit
and i'm going to rerun my initial script
just to clear the table so drop table
and then recreate it
insert value one again and then comment
so now the table is back to how
it looked before so here let me log in
again
so this is repeatable read setting
right so remember that the
default value for this isolation
setting is always read committed so
if i change it to repeatable read
right and then check the value again
then you can see
this so and again remember
or show variables is the command to
check the current value
and then set is the command to set
uh the configuration right so i will put
all these commands in like a git
github repo file then you can actually
grab the commands from there and then
you can try them yourself
basically i'm changing the i'm changing
the setting
from read committed to repeatable read
right so i'm going to just
start a new transaction over here in
here
i'm going to update this value to 2
and over here i'm going to run the
select query
that we saw before just selecting
everything from this table
and you see that the value is currently
one and that makes sense
so let me go ahead and run commit and
if i ran the same query again i see
the value one and this is the same
as the value that was read before
even though the data was changed by this
other session and then committed within
this
transaction the data that we are seeing
is the same
in in other terms
basically we are we are reading the same
data
or the the reads are being repeated
right
so that is the third setting and the
last one
is the most strict
locking configuration so which is
called serializable so i'm going to
as usual i'm going to drop the table and
then just recreate them
recreated inserted value 1 again
and then i commit so here i'm going to
log in again
and uh as usual the default setting
is read committed right
so let's check that first just to show
you
and then i'm gonna change it to serial
serializable so
what this means is basically
i'm going to start a transaction so on
the first session
i'm going to run an update basically
changing the value from 1
to 2. and here
i'm going to start a transaction and i'm
going to run
a query on that table right and now this
query
even though it's just a select a select
is just a read
it's not updating it's not deleting or
doing anything it's just a read
it is waiting because
uh the update is basically updating this
data
and then it's not database mysql
database is
not even letting this read or the select
query from
the other session to see the data so
this is
the most strict setting actually
so if i do a commit over here then on
this other session you will see that
the query has written and it's seeing
the latest
value right so if i go ahead
and run another select of course it's
returning the same thing
but if i try to update this value from
2 to 3 another update
that is basically going to wait on the
select basically this transaction that
is running right now because the select
again select is just a read it is
just reading the data but still it is
locking that
row in the database and it's not letting
any updates or modifications to that
data
and then you can see that the update
even failed because it
waited for some time and then the
timeout value exceeded
so we don't have to go into those
details but i'm going to try updating
now
and here i am just going to exit out of
this session
which will release all the locks and
that will help the
update to go through and then i can
commit and
exit as well and how you hope it was
clear to you guys
and if you have any questions please put
it in the comments
and reach out to me somehow i know you
can figure out i'll see you guys in the
next section
hey my sequel learners so welcome back
to this new section
of my my sequel tutorial so in this
video
or in this section we're going to talk
about locks
so what are these logs right so
let's actually approach this kind of
like logically
so if you have a database and if you are
the only person
working in this database then you
basically
need not worry about anything right you
know what
you are doing so you will insert data
delete update data uh the way you want
and there is no one else trying to
intervene or interrupt your
work but unfortunately that's not the
case in
today's world if you think of a
busy ecommerce database like
amazon then then there's like a lot
going on on the on those websites
there's like multiple people browsing
there's like a lot of people buying
stuff uh there's the people who are
selling stuff
on on these websites they're updating
data
relevant to their products so that is
basically
concurrency right so you have many users
trying to do something on this website
at the same time so how do you manage
this concurrency
that's why we need logs so
if i let everyone work on
the same data at the same time then
there's going to be a lot of confusion
and we might end up losing some data so
let me actually show you a simple
example of how that happens so i have
a table a product table
so if you've been following my tutorial
thus far we talked about this table
called products
so where we store
all the product information right
so now there's a couple of records over
here and
let's say that we have a seller
and a buyer who are working on
these records especially like this
particular record the first one which is
a book
and the book's price is this and the
quantity
i think we didn't have quantity when we
talked about it
in my previous sections but then i added
quantity here
so there's this quantity column and
there's a
there's a seller and buying buyer
interested in this record
let's look at this right so we have sort
of like a
time sequence here so what the seller
of this particular product is trying to
do is
he's trying to update the quantity of
this product
at 9 1 he is adding
60 more quantity to that product
which is you know 40 plus 60 which
100 and that's what we have
over here so then a buyer comes
and he looks at the quantity and then
he basically wants to order
two of these books that's hundred minus
ninety a hundred minus two
that's 98 and then you have the
quantity 98 over here so
this happened in a sequence so but
we are worried about concurrency right
concurrency
is like when things happen at the same
time but what if
okay first the seller comes and then he
reads the quantity
of this item initially it was 40
and then buyer comes and he also sees
that the quantity is 40
right and at 901
so the first two operations happen at
the same time at 901
seller comes and he says i want to
update
i want to add 60 more quantity
like meaning i have 60 more books of
this title but then buyer comes and he
says okay i'm buying
two items uh two of these books
so but the value that he saw
before was 40. so 40 minus 2
is 38. so
he updates the quantity to 38.
so the seller updates it to 100 but then
because of
this previous lookup the
quantity is updated to 38
due to which this whole thing
this whole operation is lost and we
end up with sort of like corrupted
data for this quantity column so this is
a simple example of
how concurrency when not managed well
might cause issue data issues like this
hey my sql learners so in this video
we are going to look at basically how
table locks works
in the context of e-commerce database
we created a simple
database or schema called ecom store
and we created a bunch of tables and i
used another dummy table to explain
um transaction isolation levels
so if you haven't seen my previous
material
go back and check it out and come back
here but then
yeah you have four tables four main
tables
and the main table that we are
interested in is
products table here and in the products
table i
inserted a couple of records these are
dummy records
so i don't have a front end or
application
running over here so we're just looking
at database right
so what what's going to happen
in this tutorial is
um so we we're going to basically
simulate a situation where
a seller is trying to
update the quantity of
the book that he is selling on this
website which
is this first book actually the common
path to uncommon success
and then the right now the quantity of
this the quantity available
you know for this book is 40 right
so he wants to update this quantity to
100
and also we'll have a couple of
more users or
buyers basically one buyer is trying to
buy the same book will have another
buyer he'll
he'll try to buy a different book
which is this book tiny habits and then
the same buyer will also try to browse
the website
like of course like we are gonna you
know have to imagine a little bit
because i don't have a friend then to
show you everything
um so let's actually see how this goes
so first of all um you know basics
first actually let's actually turn off
the auto commit
um just so
just so actually we have more control
over
what's happening and let me do that in
all the three sessions i have open
and the first session is the seller
session
the second session is the buyer one
session
and the third session is the buyer two
session
basically so i'm going to turn off the
auto commit
which is basically a mechanism that
commits automatically if it's enabled
and i don't want that so i'm disabling
it
so next is i want to show you the
transaction isolation level and we
talked about it in my
previous session so right now it's a
repeatable read
and it's the same for all so
we are going to change that to read
committed
because read committed as isolation
is the right isolation level for
oltp databases so now
well let's actually start with
the first seller session
so three sessions so the first seller
session
is gonna update the quantity of
um this book
that he's interested in or he's selling
actually
but but we are going to take this uh
aggressive approach and lock the whole
table
right so let's say the application is
written in a way that it locks the whole
products table for right and then the
other session
let's say buyer one the second session
buyer one comes
and he is gonna try
to buy two books
and how actually
we're going to do that is by running an
update so we are basically updating the
products table and we are subtracting
the quantity
by 2 which means actually the we are
buying two books and
which book is it you know the book where
by the record where product id equals
one right
so if you remember the data product id
one
is this book let's go ahead and run this
update in the second session and it's
gonna
obviously wait because the table itself
has been
locked for right by
the seller session the buyer one session
is
waiting and let's go to the buyer
two session the buyer two is trying to
buy
a different book which book is it this
other book
which is tiny habits book where
product id equals two and
we're going to do that and of course
even
that is hanging or waiting
and that is actually a little bit
crazy isn't it so if uh just seller is
trying to update the quantity of this
one record
with this one book and everything is
hanging and the buyer
two who's trying to buy a different book
he kind of gives up
so he moves to a different session and
instead of
buying or trying to buy a book
he just tries to browse
uh the website which is a select query
or a read query rate a select query
which is also hanging so the
buyer 2 is getting frustrated right now
so you can see how restricted this kind
of
uh sequence is so if someone's using
table
logs it's going to basically reduce the
concurrency
of the operations that can happen
in this database so that's the main
point here in this demo
[Music]
okay my sequel learners so
in this session we are going to take a
brief look at
row level logs in mysql i have three
sessions i'm already connected to my
e-commerce database my sql database
and this is how the data looks now so
we have a products table which holds
um you know this data only two books now
just dummy data that i created
and this this is the price and you have
the quantity column
showing you how many how much quantity
is left
for each of these books so the first
session is
a seller session the second
session is a buyer session
we can call this buyer one session and
the third session is
a buyer two session
so this is the data and just for clarity
actually
i wanted to show you the transaction
isolation
setting which is read committed and
the auto commit is turned to
uh turned off basically it's disabled
so unless i commit explicitly
uh my transactions will not be
permanent
so let's actually start with a seller
uh he's going on the website or a portal
that he has available
to update the inventory of let's say the
book
one right or the product one which is
this book
and so he's going to
click some buttons which is going to
translate to
an update statement
being executed in this database right
so let's say he wants to increase the
the number of books available in the
inventory so that will mean
quantity is going to be increasing
incremented by 50 so that's the update
statement
and he's going to run that update
and we can
look at
the buyer one session let's say buyer
one
is trying to buy the same book
and
and then so he's going to go on the
website and then
click on buy now or whatever
and that is going to translate into this
update statement in the database
which is quantity equals quantity minus
one
so reducing the quantity by one meaning
he's buying uh buying a book and of
course there's going to be
you know other statements updating other
tables
but then to keep it simple i'm just
showing you
the products table changes section
so as you can see this is gonna wait
because seller is updating
this particular row actually
and that can be um
seen using a query
on data logs
so if you're in the uh
this query of course you can modify this
query as per
your needs but then if you query this
you will see that
there's bunch of sessions and there's
here's the lock mode column and then
the table on which the database on which
the logs are
happening the table so it gives you a
lot of details
so so if you want to understand what's
going on here
so we have products table and then
we have ix lock which is intention
exclusive lock on the table itself
meaning like a transaction is about to
get an exclusive lock
and this is at the table level but don't
get
tricked by that there's also another
row indicating there is a record level
or a row level lock
and and that is locking only
this uh data
equals one so if you remember our update
statement we are using product id
so and the data for which
is one actually so product id equals one
so that's what we are seeing over here
and if you see here this buyer session
has actually timed out already so he's
gonna
attempt to buy again so that's how
like you can actually look at the
locking details in this table
let's try let's say like buyer 2
comes in at this point and then he
just tries to browse the the inventory
on this e-commerce website
so that would mean a select query a read
query
and he's he's able to do this happily
actually
right so there is no problem so while
the row logs are happening
other sessions can read this table they
can even look at the data
for the same product but they they just
cannot
buy this book because that is being
locked by
the seller so again it timed out so at
this point buyer 2 wants to
buy a different book you know i'm not
able to buy this book let me try buying
a different book
that's going to translate to you know
product id
id equals 2 which is not being locked by
the seller
and then that update goes through and at
this point let's say the seller has
completed updating the inventory
and of course if you look at the data
now it's going to look different
because this has been updated to 150
and of course this hasn't gone down
because
buyer buyer one is still in the process
of buying the book
because the commit has not happened yet
in the application and then if we look
at the data again
the data has gone down but
the quantity has gone down and then
buy a two let's say wants to buy the
first
book that buyer one wanted to buy
at this point there are no no locks in
this table
because everyone's committed
and let's say buyer
2 is trying to buy this this book
and then he goes through
with the update and then comments
and look at data
and then the data is changing actually
so this is how a row level lock
basically
allows for high concurrency
so only the rows which are locked by
your transactions
are not available for these other
sessions to modify
right so the other records
which are not touched by your
transactions
are available for updating deleting etc
and all of course you can add new books
that means
inserting new records in this table
so i just wanted to show you the
difference between
table level logs and row level logs
so this session and my previous session
will uh will be useful in understanding
the difference thank you i'll see you in
my next session
in this session uh we're going to be
talking about
deadlocks and i just want to show you
how deadlocks happen
they do happen in uh in a busy
ecommerce ottp uh
database often so it's good to
know what they are so and it's gonna be
a very
uh short and sweet session so
here we have a couple of sessions again
so connecting a connected to the same
database
there's two sessions two different
sessions so let's
say that we are working with
a product stable right so
we have seen this table before in my
previous sessions
basically this table has information
about the products that
are being sold on uh
you know an e-commerce website so we
have a couple of records over here
you know we're going to first let's say
you know a seller comes to actually
update the quantity of this product
basically let's say if he wants to
increase the quantity by
25 for this first
book this is the command that he is you
know that's going to be executed
you know whatever buttons he's clicking
will be translated to an update command
like this
right and uh let's say like a different
person from the same company wants to
update the price of this book
not this book let's say we have the
other book i'm just actually using the
product
id to you know update the the right
product right
so we have one session where seller one
is updating the quantity of this item
we have another session where we are
updating the
uh price of this item and then if you
see the price is incremented by two
let's say two dollars
and this is fine right so now we have
row level locks
so this guy is holding a row level lock
on this
row and this guy is
holding a row level lock on this row so
this is fine right so we are operating
on
two different records two different
locks
independent of each other all good so
now let's say
on the same seller the second
person who is updating
uh the price wants to update the
price of this other book too actually
like he is actually increasing the price
again by two dollars of this book
the product id equals one which book
this one right here
let's go ahead and try to increment the
price by running this command
you know he's waiting on waiting for the
lock actually
exclusive lock and that's not available
because
this seller has not committed actually
is not committed
so let's actually go back here and
and this seller at the same time tries
to update the price of
or quantity of this book so two sessions
are
fighting for pretty much the same
resource
you know we ended up in a deadlock
situation
so my sequel was
smart enough to just kill the session
otherwise we would have
two sessions waiting for each other
endlessly
right so here you can see
the error code that is thrown it says
deadlock
found when trying to get lock and try
restarting the transaction
so let's go ahead and query the the
products table
and see how it looks
you can see that this whole transaction
was rolled back
correct both the transactions were
rolled back
this even this one was rolled back
so i think that lock was also killed
so that's why this this one went through
and if you can see the prices have
increased by two dollars right because
initially it was 1699 and 2039
and here 1899 and 20 to 39.
okay so that's how it works
okay this is a typical deadlock
situation
i hope this explanation was clear and i
will see you guys in my next session
all right my sql learners so in this
session we are going to talk about
clustered
indexes so
so clustered index is not a different
index type as in like
you can uh you know directly clear
create a clustered index yourself so it
is a type of index that
uh that my sequel kind of maintains in
the you know behind the scenes actually
so
and also your table data the data that
you insert into your tables
or load into your tables are maintained
in these indexes
indexes only what i mean by that is so
let's say this is a b
tree index right so this is a b tree
index so you have
my sql creating this b tree index
as you load data into these tables
and then you know in the leaf notes
what you have is actually the data the
data that you're loading into these
tables
right you know the clustering the
sorting is
based on the primary key that you define
or you know in this table actually so if
you don't define a primary key
mysql will automatically pick up
uh a non-nullable
index key what that means is so
let's say that in fact actually let's
jump straight into the example that i
have
prepared for you guys so
so this is my my sequel workbench and
you know i'll show you uh this
table definition so this is called
products underscore
one and it's basically a products table
that
is typically used in a e-commerce store
and if you've been following my lessons
this is what i've been using i just
changed the
name of the table for uh you know
demonstrating
this concept this clustering clustered
index concept
so you have all these like columns and
i'm defining a primary key
okay so let's just start by you know
i'm just going to switch to a database
called ecom store or schema called
e-com store i'm gonna drop you know
these tables if they
exist already by any chance um
so the table doesn't exist which is okay
so i'm gonna create
uh this table which i just talked about
called products
and then this table has
primary key uh
uh in a primary key as product id so
product id is
sort of like an integer column so this
is an auto increment right so you don't
even have to
provide a value for this column actually
when you load the data so you can just
put
all this information and load it and
then we we are good
mysql will automatically increment the
value of this column actually
so and then of course like i said like
there is
a isbn column which is over here
sort of like book isbn information if
you are
you know if you remember your school
days like there is this isbn number
attached with
any book so something like that so
some kind of isbn alpha numeric number
so i'm going to call that like a
a unique key or a unique constraint
and let's go ahead and create this table
and this constraint
so that was successfully created and i'm
going to create a
a procedure uh which i can use to
kind of like populate this table right
so don't worry about the details of this
procedure this is something that i
wrote to populate the table
and then that is successfully created
and change the delimiter back to a
semicolon
and then i'm going to call this
procedure and which is going to throw
some warnings which is okay
with me as long as um
as long as the data gets populated i'm
fine so it's going to
probably generate some you know load
some 6000 plus rows into this
table so we'll see how much we get
this is awesome so it's actually loading
a lot of data
it seems to be done so let's go ahead
and commit the data
and uh you know now actually i'm going
to
select the data in this table right
um just select all the data and you will
see that
the data by default or the data is
actually sorted based on the primary key
which is product id
and you can see you know i haven't like
specified any ordering so this is
you know this is the the default
ordering of data
right and so basically your table data
is sorted based on your
clustered index which is primary key
over here
because you have the primary key in the
table actually
right so now the next thing is actually
i'm going to create a similar table
which is
you know which i'm going to call it
products2 but in this case i'm going to
basically not define a primary key
i'm still going to have a unique key
called
again the same thing you know it's isbn
it's a unique key
and uh let's just give it a different
name just so we have
kind of like we have different names for
different constraints
so let's actually go ahead and create
this table
and so this table is created
i'm going to copy the data from the
first
table that you know where i loaded a lot
of data so i'm going to copy the data
from that table into this table right so
which is very simple and then i'm going
to commit
right so that's about six four five five
sixty four fifty five 455 number of rows
inserted into this table
and i'm going to select all the
rows from this table and you can see
that now the data is not sorted uh
by product id rather it is sorted by
this isbn
it is sorting based on first character
first and then initially
the first and second characters are the
same then
0 1 0 2 and that keeps going 0
5 and then 0 9 0 a
b c d f g h and then
having after the zeros you know c 1 so
it is basically
sorting data based on isbn and why
isbn because because of the absence of
primary key it's going to choose this
isbn column
as uh or this it's going to choose this
non-nullable unique index
key which is based on isbn column
right so it's sorting based on this but
this is actually a terrible terrible
idea because
if you're generating random alphanumeric
string
for isbn you know then
you're not going to be generating the
string in sort of like an
ascending order or in any type of order
actually so in that case actually
you know when you're as you're inserting
data
into this table this b3 is going to be
created behind the scenes and then my
sequel
like whatever program is creating or
maintaining this data structure behind
the scenes has to work
really really hard to manage this b3
index actually right
that's why this is a terrible idea to
have like a uuid
or a some kind of alphanumeric string as
a primary key actually
or in the absence of primary key
well mysql is going to use this this key
for clustering
and again it is very bad so keep that in
mind when you're creating tables
actually
right so finally what i'm going to do is
create
another table uh called products3 and
before that i'm going to show you
the output of this query which is
basically going to come up uh empty or
you know no no wrote rows written
all i'm doing is actually checking
whether this
index the index with name gen clust
index
is there in this database actually and
then i'm checking the
inner db tables and information schema
i'm joining
in odb tables and nodb indexes and
checking whether this
index indeed exists right so
it doesn't exist which is where the this
uh
this query returned no rows and i'm
going to create this table and this time
i'm not even going to create the
create a unique key and i'm going to
make all these columns as
like nullable columns you know so
i just want to show you what happens
when you have a scenario
uh where you're creating a table with
all nullable columns and no primary key
index
no unique not nullable index
and you know and then i'm going to
insert
data into this table
again 6400 plus rows inserted
commit and then i'm going to select from
this product 3 table right now
and when the data comes up you can see
that there is still some ordering
that's happening and you know we don't
have any of these options primary key or
not nullable unique key available then
how is
my sequel able to sort data what is it
using
so it actually uses a hidden um
hidden key actually right a hidden
primary key
so if you run the same query again
this query you can see that this index
has been created on products
three table which is maintained
internally by
my sequel for just the purpose of
clustering this table actually
okay so that's a lot of information i
hope you found this
useful and i will see you guys in my
next video
hello my sequel learners so in this
session i want to
teach you the basics of using explain
or explain plan in my sequel all right
so now let's just let me just show you
the table that i'm going to be working
with i'm going to be working with a
table called products underscore one
and it's got some na in a product name
product type price and if the product is
a book
it will have an isbn number attached
with it
uh and then there's a quantity column so
these are some basic columns that you
would see in an e-commerce
online store so let's get started by
just looking at the indexes
of this table so this basically has
two indexes one is a primary key
index uh which is on the product id
and the other one is uh an index on the
isbn column and this is a unique index
actually
so let's get started by
picking a simple query that we are gonna
uh kind of like optimize using explain
so the the query that i'm gonna be using
is this
so i'm going to be selecting isbn from
this products underscore one table where
product name
has cat in it so
the product name is cat okay
so and before i run this query i'm going
to look at the
explain plan of it and i'm going gonna
put
a slash g at the end so i get
the output in the in a readable format
so first of
all uh it gives this output
right and select is
just one straights simple select that's
what
this is showing but the main thing is we
are working with
or this particular row is referring to
this
table and apart from that actually you
have all these columns and then they are
all
null right now like they don't make much
sense apart from this
so this is a typed column and
all means that it is doing a full table
scan
uh basically my sql is doing a full
table scan it scanning the whole
table and how many rows is that it's
these many rows and we are using a
filter over here
it gets all those rows and then it
filters the output
and basically a
you know there's about uh 600
uh rose with product name equals cat
right so the filtered percentage is like
10
basically and then there is some extra
information
let's go ahead and create an index on
this table
create index called you know we can give
an
arbitrary name and
and i'm going to create it on products1
table and the column is
product name of course this is the
column on which i'm creating the index
actually let's just go ahead and run the
explain again
so this is the explained plan
and that's how it looks
so basically you can see that the
again it's pretty much the same kind of
output but
this time it is also showing some data
for all these columns
so first of all possible keys column
shows like
all the indexes that this query can
use and and out of which like this
is the key or index that it is
uh you know it is going to use this
particular execution is going to use
and this is the key length in bytes
actually
right the number of rows that is being
scanned
uh in this key just 589
and you know since this is index based
we're not really filtering data rather
we're just going to the index and
getting the data
so there is no filtering over there
let's actually
create another index which
also includes isbn and
see like what happens actually i'm going
to create
the other index
and give it a different name
so let's go ahead and run the explain
plan again
so now again the possible keys
are these two indexes
but it still chooses to go with this
particular index
and the index key length is the same
and then rows and etc etc so there's no
filtering that happened right
because we're choosing an index so you
might be wondering like you know why
it's not using uh uh
the covering index right so this is
supposed to be the covering index and
covering indexes are supposed to be
better than normal
non-clustered index or a secondary index
so you can actually like use a
format like json format to get
more information so how you can do that
is by just specifying like format equals
json
and use the
use that and
so that's going to give you the output
in json format
and you can see that you know it gives
you a little bit more information as in
like the query cost
you know this is how much it's going to
cost for my sequel to execute this query
and this
is you know a representation of the
amount of
work uh mysql has to do
to run this query actually so the
cost for this one is 76 90
right and then again it says these are
the possible keys
and used key is used keep hearts is
product name
which was not given over here
and then there's a cost info which is
a split of where the cost is going
so you can read my sequel documentation
on all these
fields you know you might be wondering
why the covering index is not being used
and we can actually force that
index by using this
use index
syntax or use index keyword
and then i'm going to put the index name
that i want to force which is this one
and when i run it this
run the explain plan this time it shows
the cost of
this one is going to be 109.27
uh you know in comparison to the
previous explain
plan where the cost is only 76
and this is why uh my sequel is going
with
this particular plan instead of this guy
okay i hope this session was useful